hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to The Forgotten project of
the Damned an indie horror game unlike
any other in that I have no idea what
it's about okay information about the
factory this factory was built in 1980
as ordered by government this Factory is
built for experiment as suspicious and
weird creature that we found in an
island will trap the creature and do
some research and intensive testing
we'll make sure that the subject will
stay in this factory forever until
government tells us to set it free
sounds like a paranoid guy that's
talking about oh wait those a door that
I came in this building there was a
little intro sequence that I went
through but there was like a graphical
bug so I didn't include it okay so let's
do this now I haven't been playing a ton
of any horror games especially ones like
this which are you know made by an
individual and they may be of good or
bad quality I'm not entirely sure but
let's see excuse me I would like to get
out thank you excuse me I would like to
get out your door thank you door is
locked okey-dokey then
lab is boarded up with wood find
something to break with okay I'll play
your game alrighty then someone who's
not happy with the dinner situation here
some broken stuff tables things I like
the ambiance door is locked
any one of these that I could use to
break it off with oh well that'll help
crowbar always useful okay let's see
what you got excuse me god damn it
alright there we go I seem to be getting
stuck on a few things and I can't say
that that's just a ton of level detail
in this but I'm gonna suspend my
disbelief just for a moment here Oh what
oh okay there we go
had to crouch under that that was in the
readme he said he modeled things a few a
few things he said he modelled a few
things wrongly and ergo had to uh inform
people to crouch under certain doorways
okay
there we go got the water down so that
was good huh oh hi excuse me was that
the thing from dead space that was
wasn't it
oh cool at least there's a familiar face
over here my vision seemed to have gone
a little bit staticky
okay not this one - what's that that a
note we have confirmed that the monster
is created by chemicals that been
released to see from some factory that's
pretty vague man that's that's like
Godzilla he was from radiation or
radioactive chemicals no one really
knows the signs of it
oh whoa okay auto latch onto this ladder
tajalli decides as I can okay so now
that that moment of panic is over let's
see what else do you find tools to fix
the boat oh okay oh okay I got a Crouch
under basically every doorway he must
have just done a miscalculation on how
tall the actual character was all right
come on come on I'm ready for it
I've got permanent film grain on my
eyeballs now what's that it's a tool
it's a tool alright I'm a tool can I use
me could I bash my head up against the
boat and fix it
ham are good okay finding it pretty
quickly wait you can't leave until you
found something that you need why can't
I leave I'd like to leave I got a hammer
and a screw oh okay I got you
what Oh monster was captured on that
date during the infiltration of the
island subject is violent and killed two
men whilst being transported to the
facility skin burns went into wreck
contact with sunlight was kept in
solitary unit walls tests were conducted
some days xscape during 1989 power
outage hasn't been seen since evacuation
is almost complete too dangerous to stay
in the island okay so everyone else is
not dead everyone else is actually alive
what what else do I need
I thought I took that oh I get it oh
okay I see there we go God haha what
that's a gate [ __ ] oh my god you son of
a [ __ ] look God what the hell lose the
enemy before you go on always behind me
go piss and balls Oh piss oh god damn it
my heart flies
oh my ah jump Oh piss I'm dead okay
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die oh but I
died oh he's gonna get me ah I can't go
around him he's blocking my path oh well
there we go
I'm still alive somehow I don't know how
but I am okay how do i how do I lose him
this door was locked it said I couldn't
open it ah piss Oh what do I do this
suddenly got way more intense oh there
we go now I can open it oh those those
like excessively intense you can't just
throw that at me game although I
appreciate your candor I like to color
your jib I like the style of your but I
like um so uh so was he gone now
god damn it these damn doors good god I
don't even think those supposed to scare
me as much as it did this is all of a
sudden he was kind of there okay anyway
that looks pretty good I didn't mind
that I didn't mind it so what am I
supposed to do I've got multiple keys Oh
is there another key in that room over
there that might have been goddamn these
doors don't you do that again to me you
can't be here again it's not allowed
it's against the rules
my the only one who cares about the
rules okay so there's got to be
something else in here that I need right
God my vision is permanently Wonka fide
oh whoa oh whoa oh I see it okay cool
got it got it got it got it
okay so it is to the other door I gotta
not step out of the way of the door I
can just go through it I'm just kind of
unfortunate what
me me no how about this you like some of
us cuz I got a lot of it
oh I'm pulling it right out of my
pockets okay whatever shut up shut up
shut up shut okay who is it
who's there oh god I can't even answer
the door
how am I supposed to do okay I can go
through this object apparently how much
folks
oh I get it uh-oh the sunlight thing it
doesn't like light oh I mean my
flashlight was supposed to get it
hello is someone hot and bothered over
here is someone rather frazzled can I
get out now I can close that door behind
me no matter I'm not here baby woo ha
got it I got it oh well I don't know
okay Hey oh I'm back outside oh okay I'm
out here baby
it's not even on the ocean I don't think
it is this is that
oh hi nice feet if I had a foot fetish
this would be very bad cuz those are bad
feet hey that's the end nice short and
sweet one tip all right there you go
I'm pretty sure this music is not
allowed so I'm gonna you can't hear
anything right now you guys can't hear
anything so anyway that was uh those not
bad I mean that one scare got me real
good but I think that was this more of a
coincidence of the situation than what
it actually was
although the like it was pretty intense
I will give you that anyway it wasn't
bad if you want to play this the link is
obviously in the description below thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye welcome to let's play the demo
jump to see you okay we gotta put the
season tire together as well
yeah we got tap deal or right to Excel
Oh rain